[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce numéro de paf
consacrée aux élections départementales
et régionales qui ont eu lieu hier avec
un grand nombre d'invités
sandrine grand bonjour bonjour vous êtes
maire-adjointe de trappes conseiller
régional et représentent deux
générations s jacques chesnais bonjour
bonjour vous êtes de ceux kata fédéral
du parti socialiste patricia millau
bonjour bonjour à la co secrétaire
départemental de europe ecologie les
verts
et puis jean baptiste à monique bonjour
vous êtes le maire de vue du prêt vous
êtes le président du modem des yvelines
et en plateau sébastien ramage bonjour
bonjour vous êtes membre de la france
insoumise conseiller municipal de
billancourt et était tête de liste sur
la liste de clémentine autain aux
régionales
cyril août bonjour alors cette mort du
rassemblement national 2 est il candidat
à vous êtes toujours candidat donc cela
jeudi face notamment à pierre bédier
laurent mazaury bonjour lapointe
d'elancourt vice-présidence de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et moncton
idei et pierre luce vous êtes délégué
départemental de la république en marche
voilà pour les yvelines alors on va
peut-être commencer par le bas le
premier thème c'est une mode et si au
fond la démocratie n'est pas blessée par
par l'abstention record de ce vote de
dimanche
[Musique]
d'abord votre votre sentiment 67 66 68 %
d'abstention c'est une catastrophe
démocratique
oui c'est vraiment parler de crise
démocratique les français viennent de
subir une crise sanitaire
une crise sans doute économique et
sociale qui va qui va survenir et qui va
durer un certain temps une crise
sécuritaire et maintenant maintenant
nous payons les conséquences de tout
cela avec cette crise démocratique les
français ne se sont pas déplacés la
participation des français au vote elle
dépend des gens qui autour de cette
table des politiques et alors on va
d'abord d'abord si vous ne bougez pas on
voit peut-être des courses à strophes
oui oui effectivement là on va voir de
cette catastrophe mais bon pour vous
l'euro majorie oui bien sûr c'est une
catastrophe que je pense que l'on paye
aussi des années les dizaines d'années
d'erreurs en matière de communication
politique y compris quand on a réformé
un seul homme de loi et qu'on a voulu
plus de transparence sur la ville
politique en même temps on a interdit
les campagnes d'affichage extérieur et
on a transféré en fait une partie du
dialogue politique vers les réseaux
sociaux
et aujourd'hui les gens pensent au lieu
de voter que quand il s'exprime sur un
réseau social
il valide et donc qui ne vont plus voter
sandrine grand gaube sur cette extension
des manettes particulièrement c'est le
taux d'abstention chez les jeunes
tu dois vraiment voilà est un élément de
réflexion collectif parce que c'est si
notre jeunesse ne va plus voter c'est
très inquiétant pour l'avenir la jambe à
thessalonique
oui évidemment une catastrophe une
romance qui a été dit notamment
c'est plus qu'une inquiétude c'est aussi
une catastrophe sur niveau des jeunes 25
34 ans 83 % d'abstention évidemment les
raisons sont pas liées à l'acte et
sanitaires c'est beaucoup plus profond
que ça et je crois que c'est pour des
raisons si on voulait élever
collectivement qui lèvera un vrai
sursaut démocratique dans notre pays
surtout à l'aube de l'élection qui est
centrale en france qui est l'élection
présidentielle
donc ça a été dit s'accordent en tout
cas commencent à aborder le sujet je
pense que c'est plus de plus de trente
ans de politiques qui ont été menées qui
n'ont pas donné satisfaction
alors c'est très difficile c'est très
difficile de comprendre oui ou non les
et les i oui mais je pense qu'il ya
personne qui pourra satisfaire d'un tel
score après les interprétations
oui je disais que personne ne peut se
satisfaire d'un tel score dans
l'abstention c'est évident et il n'y a
aucun parti politique qui on sera
satisfait sauf que c'est les
conséquences de politiques et de et de
règles électorales qui ne correspondent
plus aux aspirations des citoyens
actuels alors qu'ida foot donc peut-être
qu on pourrait d'ailleurs dire c'est
peut-être d'abord la faute des citoyens
non on n'arrête pas de ceux de 10,2 se
plaint de la façon dont est gouvernée de
plaques de la classe politique
là il ya quand même une offre qui va de
2,2 vous de la france est soumise aux
assemblées nationales donc une offre
quand même assez large et les gens n'y
vont pas peut-être quand même qu'au lieu
de râler tout le temps faudrait
peut-être faire preuve de civisme à un
moment non un problème de confiance
peut-être surtout je pense pour toutes
les formations politiques prennent leurs
responsabilités aussi dans dans ce
manque de confiance
je parle de toutes les formations
politiques à commencer par la majorité
présidentielle dont c'était un peu le
pari de redonner confiance forte à la
démocratie force est de constater qu'on
n'a pas encore trouvé la bonne recette
pour le faire mais mais je pense que
l'ensemble des formats son petit sont
responsables y compris celles qui jouent
sur la défiance le populisme pour
essayer de gratter des voix parmi les
mécontents en cultivant ce
mécontentement et je pense qu'on n'a pas
et gagner on n'a pas gagné à faire ça et
si elle note justement c'est vrai que
vous avez fait part de c'était une
campagne départementale régionale vous
avez beaucoup parlé de sécurité de
terrorisme
d'immigration qui ne sont pas à
proprement parler les sujets de
compétences d'avoir nationalisé par la
campagne est ce que ce n'est pas une
erreur au bout non je pense pas
malheureusement ça n'a pas marché je le
regrette mais effectivement on sait que
parmi les élections qui n'attire pas les
élections régionales et départementales
sont sont les premières c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons souhaité
nationaliser le débat pour que les
électeurs les sympathisants de marie dô
de marine le pen se déplace
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas
c'est resté une élection de notables
locaux et les sortants sont sortis
renforcés c'est le cas pour les
régionales avec valérie pécresse en ile
de france par exemple c'est le cas dans
les yvelines avec les binômes soutenu
par pierre bédier et je suis le premier
à le regretter mais on sait que c'était
pas eu d'erreur de nationaliser la la
campagne vous l'avez aussi un peu
nationaliser pierre luçon par exemple
dans le nord en mettant il y avait
quatre ou cinq ministres et qui sont
revenus
c'est ça ce n'était pas une erreur
politique en tout cas que c'était une
erreur politique qui étaient des
ministres qui avaient envie de s'engager
aussi sur leur territoire ils n'ont pas
été pas recruter ils sont ils sont les
défendre des projets de territoire qui
leur tenait à coeur
et ça n'a pas suffi pour redonner
confiance en ce projet mais je pense que
personne ne regrette en tout cas d'y
avoir été d'ivoire était peut-être pas
mais d'avoir une nationaliser un peu
cette campagne qui au fond est une
campagne plutôt de territoire parce
qu'il ya un gros enjeu quand même qui
était important qui est que la
décentralisation qui passe un peu
inaperçu dans dans cette campagne
si je peux le dire mais ce que vous
disiez je vous rejoins en fait c'est que
ça a été nationalisée dans le sens où on
ne voit pas la différence entre le débat
public ces deux dernières semaines et le
débat public il ya deux mois et à trois
mois
on est toujours sur les mêmes pas de
polémique en polémique l'islam
insécurité
voilà immigration tout c'est toutes ces
choses là et en fait dans ce
gloubiboulga nauséabond qu'on nous qu'on
a sur les plateaux télé depuis trois
mois on est venu inséré l'élection
régionale ça m'étonne pas que les gens
ne sont pas allés voter ils n'étaient
pour la plupart même pas au courant de
l'existence de l'élection et en fait on
ne peut pas dire que c'est la faute des
électeurs déjà parce qu'on est en
démocratie c'est le gouvernement par et
pour le peuple et donc s'il peuple il va
pas voter c'est qu'il ya un problème au
niveau de la structure mais aussi parce
que les voilà les partis politiques
n'ont pas joué leur rôle dans leur
implication dans cette campagne et ce
qu'il a comme effet boule de neige aussi
une partie de la sphère médiatique qui
du coup le voit ne voyons pas les
politiques se se bouge et n'a pas
d'intérêt à couvrir cette même élection
est donc ça c'est un effet boule de
neige au fur et à mesure voilà on se
retrouve avec pour moi j'ai rarement vu
une élection aussi peu médiatisé qui
crée hôte aussi peu d espace politique
de débat sur les vrais sujets et je
finis là dessus effectivement les
parties certains partis de droite ont
fait le choix de d'aborder la campagne
uniquement sur l'insécurité et sur des
débats nationaux
moi je m'étonne pas en tout cas qu'on
ait du mal un peu avoir les compétences
des régions et les compétences des
départements quand il ya personne qui
accepte d'en parler des responsabilités
les têtes de liste notamment de deux
positions devant la droite d'avoir
nationalisé ça en en faisant une
primaire tout cas pour les régionales
une espèce de primaires pour les
présidentielles à grands coups justement
de sujets régaliens de jose keita qui
n'avait pas grand chose à faire
je pense que notre responsabilité nous
pardon elle est totale elle est totale
et l'historique j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure de communication moi je tenais
un bureau de vote je ne savais même pas
qu'il ait deux élections
il pensait qu'en fait j'avais deux tours
quand il venait voter donc on voit bien
qu'on n'a pas assez communiqué et on
voit bien que les canaux de
communication sont insuffisants
aujourd'hui mais je retiendrai surtout
sous un point fondamental si on veut
qu'un peuple une population vote
il faut lui apprendre ce qu'est le vote
et il faut l'éduquer civiquement et donc
ça commence à l'école qu'est ce qu'un
conseil départemental
macy gray est ce que c'est une action
territoriale qu'est ce qu'une région
quelles sont ses compétences
en gros on va dire que globalement c'est
quoi la politique c'est jeu prend de
l'argent chez des gens au niveau des
impôts et je leur dise
dans l'intérêt général eh bien comment
se fait-ce retirer cette évolution dans
l'intérêt général
à l'échelon national alléchant
départementales et régionales
aujourd'hui si vous interrogez notre
population et moi je le fais souvent
dans les écoles voyais que les enfants
ne savent pas mais on peut pas leur
reprocher personne ne leur apprend et
notre responsabilité à tous ici c'est
effectivement quand on est au pouvoir
quand on a cette capacité à faire il
faut apprendre il faut donner le savoir
si l'on peut pas ensuite reprocher aux
gens qui ne s'y intéressent pas à quoi
s'ajoute peut-être une donnée un peu
technocratique c'est vrai que si vous
regardez les compétences des
départements des régions 7 comme
extrêmement compliqué à déterminer dans
c'est vrai il ya des tableaux qui sont
absolument incompréhensible les grandes
lignes sont toujours justement patricia
uk les télés votre analyse vous de cette
abstention et des raisons de cette
abstention
moi je pense que d'avoir deux élections
avec des scrutins différents le même
jour c'est pas une bonne idée
les gens sont un peu perdus ils
comprennent pas quel type de d'élections
à quoi ça correspond vu que les scrutins
sont pas de la même façon
de toute façon je pense que la
démocratie est et est altéré par par des
scrutins incompréhensible et le choix du
mode de scrutin est très important et je
pense que beaucoup de gens attendent une
vraie représentation démocratique et
c'est pas le cas avec des scrutins comme
on en a actuellement majoritaire à deux
tours avec une prime au sort une prime
aux premiers six
je pense que ça ne correspond plus à à
ce que ce qu'attendent les gens de la
représentation
il faut pas avoir peur des
représentations des différents partis
politiques parce que les gens se sentent
non reconnu quand avec un bon
pourcentage ils n'ont pas dit lui voilà
jean baptiste est monique peut-être
votre analyse non écoutez moi je pense
qu'il ya un sujet politique auquel au
cam nou aujourd'hui n'a de réponse
on n'a pas de on essaye d'analyser les
raisons de cette de ce fort taux
d'abstention mais si on avait les
solutions dans serait pas là bon coeur
déjà ça impose un petit peu de modestie
l'humilité de la part de l'ensemble de
nos
l'action politique et donc il ya ce
sujet politique après je crois qu'il ya
un autre sujet qui est celui de
l'éducation civique et quelque part moi
je n'ai vu toute la journée d'hier en
tenant le bronze centralisateur à
villepreux les gens ne savaient pas
pourquoi ils voter pour qui est votée
qu'elle est et des compétences de la
région du département
donc je crois qu'il ya déjà des l'école
un travail assez colossal à faire et à
reprendre sur le rôle de nos
institutions sur le rôle de nos
différentes représentations et enfin je
crois qu'il ya un troisième sujet ça a
été un petit peu évoquées par patrice
familiaux et je la rejoins c'est quelque
chose en plus que nous que d'importants
vents démocrate depuis un moment
je crois qu'il est urgent de changer
aujourd'hui le système de représentation
dans ce pays et cela passera un jour ou
l'autre et je crois qu'il faut
maintenant de faire très rapidement par
la proportionnelle alors oui il ya de la
proportionnelle sur un scrutin comme les
régionales mais on voit bien que avec la
prime majoritaire qui est accordé c'est
quand même pas en véritable scrutin
proportionnel en tout cas je je je crois
que les français aspirent à être
davantage représentés d'être mieux
représentés et si des formations
politiques quelle qu'elle soit susciter
l'adhésion aussi modeste soit-il des
électeurs elles ont toute leur place
dans les différentes assemblées de nos
institutions accéder écoutez je moi j'ai
aussi tenu un bureau de vote
hier ce qui m'a marqué c'est l'âge des
électeurs alors je crois que ce qu'il
débutait savez pourquoi
venez voter et quel était le rôle du
conseil régional et du conseil
départemental
mais c'est ceux qui ne sont pas voté et
qui sont pas venus voter qu'ils
ignoraient est en effet les plus jeunes
je ne sais pas si sa race et de ressorts
de l'école l'enseignement général
pas sûr que ce soit les cours qui vont
être les plus suivis voyez si on
transfère cette cette formation
si on vous confie cette formation à
l'école mais il ya une chose qui est
certain c'est que faut bien l'avouer
aussi la crise sanitaire n'a pas et nous
nous a pas aidés à a fin notre campagne
on a aidé à rencontrer des gens et le
résultat sont fait sentir forcément
aujourd'hui
et en plus c'est dans tout pays on peut
pas dire non plus que c'est particulier
à notre département parce que là on est
en train de parler globalement
l'ensemble du pays
les yvelines d'habitude on a tous de
participation plus élevée que française
cette fois ci c'est parce que pas le cas
donc il y à vraiment profondément à
toutes les fans questions à résoudre
est-ce que c'est par la proportionnelle
je veux aussi jouent bien l'avouer art
il faut aussi que les les assemblées
puisse les présidents des assemblées
puisse jédir gérer gouverner lors tous
les conseils municipaux jean baptiste à
monique et merdes et villepreux
j'imagine que si le résultat des
élections municipales à l'épreuve était
totalement pas à la proportionnelle il
chausse trappes a forcément évident pour
gérer sa ville donc il faut trouver une
solution qui ne donne pas une prime
aussi importante à celui qui arrive en
tête mais en effet moi je suis d'accord
avec patricia il est certain que comme
andy une dose en plus tous les
présidents jusqu'à présent depuis au
moins 20 ans l'ont promis quelle que
soit leur couleur politique y compris
celui qui est aujourd'hui président d'ad
pays et aux canes côté du modem et aucun
de la bière place
d'ailleurs c'est vrai facile aux
produits sur ce plateau est la fille
pour la proportionnelle leur assemblée
nationale et pour la proportionnelle lrm
et elle ne sait plus en partir
en théorie en partie au fond il n'ya que
la droite et la gauche pour gouverner
qui sont plus réticents vis-à-vis de
cette province et dallas je pense qu'on
veut pas se contenter juste de faire la
proportionnelle à ce moment il faut
aller plus loin il faut refaire la
totalité du fonctionnement de la vème
république
sinon on pouvait pas venir coller un
système proportionnel je partage ce qu'a
dit notre collègue un instant sur
l'ensemble des élections en disant vous
aurez une cape et c'est gouverner et
repris plein doute qui s'est passé des
républiques qui nous ont précédés donc
il faut quand même professionnelle à des
gens il ça ne tarde pas avec des
attestions de la cinquième merci c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est
certainement la raison pour laquelle ça
ne s'est jamais fait c'est qu'on se
demande si on applique simplement la
proportionnelle la 5ème ne peut plus
fonctionner et par conséquent il faut
revoir la totalité du fonctionnement de
la 5e et là je suis moins sûr que
l'ensemble des parties soient d'accord
de remettre à bas la 5ème république je
pense qu'il ya des discordances beaucoup
plus importante que la simple remise en
place de la proportionnelle et puis je
vais rajouter je vais jeter une pierre
j'entends aussi un parfois denses
atteindre nos politiques avec lg plaisir
d'assister que l'abstention ça arrange
aussi certains partis suivant la
situation où les sortants vous convenait
tenteront donc c'est toujours facile le
lendemain des élections on crie tout
s'il faut l'appeler impressionnait les
saadé tous les sortants justement là que
son devoir et ça semble assez évident et
je l'entendais certains calculs
politiciens qui du coup d'ailleurs
dégoûte probablement les acteurs en dix
ans après two vient pas me chercher
parce qu'on veut pas que viennent voter
après on pourrait discuter enfin on n'a
pas le temps de faciliter aussi l'accès
au vote jeudi
pourquoi avec internet aujourd'hui on
peut passer du bon temps peut pas
faciliter les choses quand même il ya
d'autres moyens de se rendre dans un
bureau qui est toujours le même et c'est
même si déjà su rendre le vote
obligatoire patrice par exemple ou
peut-être alors il ya quand même une
question politique c'est qu'il deux
grands courants qui sont censé dominer
la vie politique 20 en tout cas pour la
présidentielle et de favori pour la
présidentielle sont les deux perdants de
ces élections
je parle de leur assemblée nationale et
l erreur et le maquereau 10 mhz si je
peux dire quand vous êtes micky sa série
le nôtre c'est vrai que les nôtres
électorale sentiment que ces sélections
ne servait à rien et en fait ils se
réservent pour l'élection prochaine
résidence et de 2022 ait jamais quand
même après ces discours il est sinistré
et défaitiste ajouté qu'il y a malgré
tout encore un second tour et qu'on peut
encore avoir un sursaut démocratique un
sursaut de participation en ile de
france bien sûr mais aussi dans les
autres régions et j'aimerais à cette
occasion rappelé que notamment en région
paca nous le rassemblement national peut
gagner une région
oui on est beaucoup plus à rien veillée
déjà manu s'est passé ne passaient pas
fait aux fêtes s'est pas fait mais c'est
faisable non non je veux dire le fait
qu'il soit battu n'est pas n'est pas
inscrit dans le marbre
exactement je suis d'accord en effet
alors c'est vrai qu'on on constate
généralement assez peu de retournement
entre les premier et deuxième tours face
est assez rare dans les actions mais ça
pourrait arriver correction un
rééquilibrage entre huy peut pas faire
pire qu'au premier tour
la pyrrhus ouais c'est au fond cette
défaite parce que les deux paires dos et
sa cc des deux favoris au fond de la
présidence ce qu'on présente comme étant
les deux favoris de la présidentielle
c'est quand cela la chute libre des
résultats du recensement national
s'explique avant tout par une incapacité
à produire un programme
quelques quel qu'il soit même parle même
pas d'un programme qui donne envie de
voter mais au moins d'un programme et il
est inexistant la preuve la
nationalisation du scrutin les a fait
tourner en boucle sur toujours les mêmes
sujets sécurité immigration terrorisme
depuis trois mois et les électeurs qui
sont conscients les compétences des
départements et des régions sont pas
dupes mérite à la réplique en marche les
s'explique aussi par un ancrage qui est
débutant c'est un mouvement récent rome
ne s'est pas fait en un jour
on peut pas demander avec quatre ans ça
fait 80 84 en effet très court le
premier scrutin départemental de
produits de maths on sait pas qu'il est
tout seul ou faux ces principes de
mouvements de yo engagés on peut pas
demander aux gens de s'engager en
politique de faire un mouvement citoyen
et en même temps d'être déjà des poids
lourds de la politique et nous ça se
construit sur le long terme
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est pas
des élections favorable ni pour le fn il
pour vous les élections locales sont pas
les élections les plus favorables à ces
niveaux j'aimerais aussi ajouté que
peut-être le problème du gouvernement de
monsieur macron c'est le en même temps
c'est à dire que on ne sait pas vraiment
qui il est il vient de la gauche il
était ministre
le françois hollande et maintenant ils
essaient de draguer la droite il ya eu
il ya eu des fusions
avant même le premier tour il ya
beaucoup de confusion autour notamment
de l'élection en pack avec ce qu est ce
qu a faire une amie juliette ça aussi je
pense que c'est très négatif et des
fastes pour la démocratie
je pense que les électeurs ils doivent
savoir pour qui ils vont voter il faut
que les hommes politiques qui se
présentent doivent être claires sur leur
programme elle est fille c'est plutôt la
partie faible au fond de la gauche non
attention à pas trop tirer de
conclusions sur des élections avec 25 %
les ont forcés de participer il faut
faire très attention c'est au tour des
élèves des décomptes niveau national sur
les élections et alors que l'enfant qui
n'a aucune leçon à tirer les fines où on
voit bien un truc c'est que on a
toujours dit que si on voulait gouverner
on devait gouverner avec le vote
populaire
là il n'y a pas eu de vote populaire on
a fait des petits scores ya une
corrélation en deçà du taux de gens âgés
déjà moi ça me rassure sur mon
positionnement politique paradoxalement
mais surtout voilà la présidentielle
c'est là où tous les pouvoirs sont
concentrés aujourd'hui
depuis tout à l'heure on parle beaucoup
de la responsabilité de toutes les
formations politiques
en vérité c'est plutôt ceux qui nous
gouvernent qui sont responsables de delà
de la détérioration de l'état du débat
public et qui sont aussi responsables de
l'organisation des élections on n'a pas
encore parlé mais j'ai quand même eu un
certain nombre de manquements l'envoi du
matériel électoral la privatisation de
l'envoi du matériel électoral dans une
période où il ya de moins en moins de
gens qui votent résultat il ya des gens
qui n'ont même pas reçu le bulletin de
vote à la maison avant le scrutin c'est
des problèmes dans l'histoire de la
cinquième jeu mais pas reçu sa première
fois j'ai 40 ans la première fois que je
ne reçois pas la propagande électorale
fiable en utilisation la poste avait une
grosse partie du marché silence os
public donc je pense que le succès
public privé n'est pas dit que ces
publics et à la poste sévit actuellement
moi j'aimerais vous dire une chose c'est
que malgré ce faible taux de
participation
le score quand même cumulé des gauches
parce que on peut parler de plusieurs
gauches en tout cas voilà alors les
différents mais bien en fait
le duo paul front national
la république en marche il est loin
d'être assurée quand moi je vois les
résultats notamment région ile de france
ou en cumulé ont fait autant que madame
pécresse alors on va voir parler dans un
un tour des régionales
jacques cedh est justement le au fond la
gauche se tient pas si mal dans ces
élections mais est ce que c'est la
gauche christian où les sortants
autistes yen est évident que la prime au
sortant a joué en tous les cas pour la
gauche
et si vous regardez les résultats en
paca manifestement certains c'est donc
là je c'est vrai que les résultats dans
les yvelines comme on se doit de mettre
de m'avoir satisfaites
et hier soir je dis heureusement qu'on a
une demo nationale des résultats qui
sont pas semblables à celui des yvelines
et qui m'ont remonté un petit peu le
moral est ce que c'est la prime au
sortant seulement voyez ce qui est très
étrange qu'on regarde la veille ce que
donnait la veille
y'a pas de sondages la veille mais les
résultats des sondages jours précédents
par rapport au résultat de cette
élection du premier tour
c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
encore fini mais ne dit on pas sur tout
ça mais ce qui est assez étonnant
d'abord c'est que là le parti socialiste
on donnait en vadrouille le père du
reste comme le premier parti de gauche
au niveau national et ceci ne veut pas
dire que je ne considère pas que il fut
la gauche
déjà tulle les écologistes dans cette
gauche se réunissent travailler ensemble
pour l'avenir y compris pour réfléchir à
ce que pourraient être ses futures
élections que l'on discréditer tout à
l'heure ça que l'on dise qu'il est la
méthode acteurs h
moi je je suis content
j'analyse le scrutin dans les aigus dans
tous les cas le résultat second tour je
vois tout simplement que sur les 21
cantons il y en a dix qui où il va y
avoir commenté un duel entre la droite
et la gauche
ce n'était pas exactement le cas il ya
six ans deux seulement
oui il va y avoir du elle la droite on
va on va éviter dans un instant là on
était juste pardon sur les sur les
grands des grandes leçons sur le tracé
remis aux batteries ciamillo où je ne
partage pas le pessimisme de jacques je
pense que bon c'est vrai je fais partie
d'un parti qui n'a pas de sortant donc
on peut pas dire qu'on est avantagée par
par la prime aux sortants mais je trouve
quand même que il faut rester très
mesuré dans nos propos parce que avec
une telle abstention rien ne veut rien
dire mais je trouve que la gauche sans
les écologistes s'en sort plutôt bien et
la gauche il et les écologistes peuvent
tout obtenir des résultats y compris
dans les yvelines
quand bien même on part d'un grand
chelem pierre bédier dans les yvelines
j'espère bien que on va casser ce grand
chelem
la semaine prochaine ok alors on va
parler justement des élections enfin des
résultats tels qu'ils sont produites
dans cette région on va commencer par
les régionales
[Musique]
il ya six listes qualifiées pour les
régionales avec valérie pécresse est en
tête on a voilà le tableau des résultats
vous êtes vous êtes déçu par le score de
laurent saint martin plus déçu c'est
toujours compliqué d'être satisfait de
ne pas avoir un score plus élevé
évidemment on est content de la campagne
qu'on a fait on est content surtout
d'être la seule formation qui est resté
droit dans ses bottes pendant toute
cette campagne on n'a jamais cédé aux
sirènes populistes et démagogiques comme
à peu près l'ensemble des autres
candidats présent à ce second tour
on a proposé un vrai progrès
progressistes pour la région et on va
continuer à le défendre pour le second
tour et donc vous vous rappelez un
second tour jean baptiste à monique
justement alors dans le modem il ya
certains manques du modem au avait
rejoint valérie pécresse dans sa liste
d'autres étaient sur la réglisse de
laurent saint martin
vous regrettez pas vous d'abord ne pas
avoir soutenu directement pécresse je
pense pas que vous posez la question à
ces termes là pour regarder maintenant
comment aborder le second tour moi ma ma
position j'avais déjà eu l'occasion
d'exprimer à titre individuel après les
plus forts le ya un dénominateur commun
à trouver à chaque fois dans une
formation politique et puis après on
verrouille chose qui a été convenu donc
je ressasse pas le passé maintenant ce
qui est important c'est de regarder vers
l'avenir
ce que je note parce qu'on a parlé
d'implantation locale et je crois que
c'est coeur du sujet quand on aborde des
élections départementales et des
élections régionales
regardez le score que font les deux
têtes de liste modem en france
je pense à geneviève darrieussecq et à
marc fesneau ville soit entre 15 et 17%
ce sont les deux meilleurs résultats
pour la majorité présidentielle
et comment cela s'explique pourquoi cela
pourquoi cette raison enfin pourquoi en
tout cas c'est score le jeu qu'on croit
que lui alors entation d'un camion
quelque part je rejoins aussi fier lui
quand il dit que la république aux
marches est un jeune parti politique un
jeune mouvement qu'il a besoin de se
structurer dans le temps quand nous nous
avons des élus locaux et des figures
locales un peu plus un peu plus connus
qui ont oeuvré aussi à différents
échelons
c'est plus facile moi je crois que là où
on a commis une erreur et je me dis très
clairement
contrairement à ce qu'a fait valérie
pécresse elle l'a très bien compris
c'est que quand on aborde des scrutins
de ce type
hormis les têtes de listes
départementales hormis la tête de liste
régionale
je crois qu'il faut vraiment construire
une liste sur les ennemis look avec les
locaux sinon malgré nous on nationalise
le scrutin si nous avons des
parlementaires si nous avons des
ministres et ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose que la majorité
présidentielle doit tirer comme
enseignement ensuite sur la région ile
de france plus précisément je rejoins ce
qui a été dit par délégué de la
république en marche
on combat un programme qui a été élaboré
en commun qui est un bon programme qui
fait sens avec de belles propositions et
je crois pas que ce soit ce soit jouée
finalement sur sur cela on parlait de
jeu par l implantation de cada l'instant
l'implantation de quel évidemment des
sortants d'ailleurs ça a été dit par
jacques chesnais
l'analyse et les scores national des
élections que ce soit des sortants de
gauche ou de droite
si les lecteurs me connaît le sortant et
juge que le bilan est plutôt correct il
se pose pas de question et je crois même
qu'il n'ira même pas regarder en détail
des programmes musicaux
donc il ya vraiment encore une fois un
sujet je crois d'éducation aussi civique
et de sensibilisation à le pourquoi du
comment de ces scrutins
à quoi cela sert-il d'avoir aujourd'hui
en france des conseillers départementaux
des conseillers régionaux et comment ces
deux collectivités peuvent venir à
bouger les choses en tout cas apporté
une amélioration donc quand il dans le
quotidien des franciliens ou des
français et ça je crois que ça a été mal
perçu parce que oui que ceux qui ne se
sont pas déplacés non styles sont pas
intéressés n'ont pas compris mais on a
aussi des personnes pour qui le vote est
un acte citoyen très importants qui sont
venus voter mais on a bien eu la
sensation dans les bureaux de vote que
les gens venez voter par habitude pour
ceux qui sont revenus mais je crois pas
qu'il ait toujours eu forcément un vote
d'adhésion
il est juste un mot patrie si vous me
permettez parce que sarko n'aime pas ça
n'a pas encore été dit la politique
pendant la cuve accident dans la crise
sanitaire du gouvernement a été
fortement critiquée imaginez s'il avait
été différente parce que si aujourd'hui
nous n'avions pas vacciner en priorité
les seniors et jusqu'au 55 50 ans je
crois que le taux d'abstention monte
nous sommes tous en train de dire qu'il
est catastrophique ce matin serait de
l'ordre de 10%
donc moi je tiens aussi à remettre un
peu les choses en perspective et si nous
n'avions pas eu de la part du
gouvernement cette politique là pendant
la crise sanitaire les résultats
auraient été encore plus catastrophique
jean baptiste que vous nous dites
surtout pas que les vaccinations et
agile et c'est pour qu'ils puissent
venir voter aux prochaines sélections
disais juste que la séquence je dis
juste que c'est parce que j'ai dit je
dirige le si on n'avait pas avancé aussi
rapidement sur la vaccination en
commençant par les plus fragiles
évidemment on aurait eu évidemment de
personnes dans les bureaux de vote hier
pourquoi
série de notes le score de jordan
bardella 1,13 un peu plus de 13 pour toi
c'est beaucoup moins que ce qui était
annoncé
écoutez écoutez bon on sait que la
région ile de france est la région la
plus utilisée pour le rassemblement
national nous nous avons perdu des voix
nous baissons également en pourcentage
en revanche nous sommes en seconde
position ce qui n'était pas le cas en
2015 donc voilà j'appelle tous les
franciliens et aussi oui mais c'était il
y aurait plusieurs listes de gauche en
2015 aussi et c'était de me claude
bartolone qui était en 2e position assez
largement
mais encore une fois oui j'appelle des
franciliens donc à venir au second tour
pour que nous ayons le le groupe lui le
plus puissant possible nombre d'élus de
plus le plus important possible pour
pour incarner 7,7 cette opposition à
valérie à la valérie pécresse et pour
lui mettre la pression pour qu'ils ne
cèdent pas aux dérives de la gauche la
trezia millau julien bayou et est en
tête de la gauche si je peux dire donc
ça sera lui pour vaillamment une union
je parle sous comptant le déchet bastien
ramage d'entre elle est fille le ps ee
et les verts
pour vous c'est forcément une
satisfaction mais ce qu'il est en mesure
d'être rassembleur genia bayou alors je
voudrais dire d'abord que oui on est
très content julien bayou et le premier
de de la gauche et des écologistes parce
que je pense que les écologistes se
reconnaissent pas forcément dans ce
qu'on appelle la gauche et donc je pense
que c'est important de dire que c'est un
rassemblement d de la gauche autour de
julien bayou les négociations étaient
prévisibles
il n'y a pas de y'a pas d'entourloupe
sur ce second tour il avait été dit dès
le départ que y aura une fusion derrière
le mieux placé et c'est ce qui se passe
j'entends que la reine elle est droit
dans ses bottes mais je ne sais pas très
bien quelle bottes alarm ce que je sais
c'est que le programme écologiste était
très clair et qu' il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui seront qui
perdureront dans ce dans un programme
qui va s'établir entre eux les trois
candidats de de la gauche et des
écologistes et nous en sommes très
contents les bottes de l'horeb alors que
entre critiquer la réplique en marge
d'un rassemblement national visiblement
les écologistes ont fait leur choix il
ya qui critiquent plus ça va très vite
depuis le début c'est toi une espèce
d'aura utilise un peu bizarres sur sur
ces sujets là chacun d'entre eux a bercé
les choses là ça peut vous fait dire ça
c'est à dire que votre votre principal
ennemi c'est le ressenti de ce mode de
dire que les écologistes ne sont pas
préfère le rn alarm c'est quand même un
peu exagéré d'autant que il me semble
que historiquement les écologistes ont
toujours été très très vent debout
contre toutes les idées d'extrême droite
donc c'est un peu difficile d'entendre
que les écologistes préfèrerais le
rassemblement alarm faut pas déformer la
réalité comme jacques cd pulvar en 10 %
c'est une claque pour il est le gouv
écoutez moi je sais pas la campagne de
haine et algo je vous rappelle que ça
c'est la campagne de la presse pas la
nôtre
nous on n'a pas désigné notre candidat
et je vous ne me rappelle même que à
toutes les portes sont ouvertes pour que
le candidat soit pas forcément à
socialiste je répète simplement les mots
de notre premier secrétaire donc le ne
m'amenez pas ne m'amenez pas sur ce
terrain là nouveau tueur audrey pulvar
qui n'est pas socialiste
une fois et bombe à écouter les
électeurs font leur choix nous on fasse
on va se réunir on va d'abord les
réunions déjà sous des gens courent le
rassemblement va se faire si vous avez
regardé les quelques c'était très faible
dans cette campagne je suis assez
d'accord avec je crois que c'était jean
baptiste aman et qui souligne et qui
avait une très petite tribu de deux
débats dans les médias y compris
d'ailleurs bizarrement très peu de
papiers dans la presse écrite mais est
toujours est il que
quand vous suiviez les peu de débat qui
a eu je crois sur fr3 lci
moi ce qui m'a frappé le plus c'est la
convergence qu'il y avait entre les les
trois listes de gauche et mon profond
regret c'est que les paillettes on était
assez stupide tous pour continuer à nous
présenter au premier tour comme ça se
fait plus très longtemps séparées alors
qu'aujourd'hui on serait on dessine une
situation tellement 33% en 34 % ça
changerait un peu les choses non bien
sûr
dormez josé milliot la position de
patricia est totalement différente
ça va être facile à terre au 2e tour de
dire et masterimage aussi les gens qui
votent plus facilement pour les verts
parce que parce qu'ils voteraient pas
pour la gauche
on était il m'a dit l'adage on était
inaudible sur le sujet dans une grande
partie des débats à 3 alors un seul
candidat ou une seule candidate je pense
que ça aurait été compliqué le fait est
que là on a la possibilité d'exprimer
trois sensibilités différentes que on
peut constater que globalement notre
camp notre électorat a à peu près donné
le même résultat pour chacune des trois
listes
preuve que voilà les gens s'y sont
intéressés ont pu s'accaparait programme
voilà après peu de peu de mobilisation
populaire je pense que ceux qui ont le
plus de réserves aujourd'hui c'est nous
monsieur à boni qui avait l'avantagé est
extrêmement clair sur sa vision d'une
élection il disait il faut qu'on fasse
des listes à partir dé lui je pense que
ce qui caractérise nos trois listes de
gauche c'est que nous on a fait des
listes à partir de gens qui sont
impliqués
syndicalement dans des associations qui
font partie de lutte est engagée sur sur
le territoire des gens qu'on appelle
société civile pour certains bref on a
une liste qui pour le cours reflète un
peu cette île de france qui essaie de
bouger pour que les choses changent au
quotidien sur le terrain et maintenant
c'est que quelque chose qu'il faut sur
lequel il faut s'attacher et s'accrocher
parce que je suis convaincu que le
rassemblement de ces trois listes là va
pouvoir emporter une dynamique bien plus
importante que
premier tour je pense aux déperditions à
non au contraire je pense que c'est nous
qui allons les dalits c'est nous qui
avons le plus de réserves de voix et
donc ça me paraît un peu juste pour vous
mais avant le premier tour on ne parlait
pas de ces élections leur base désormais
on en parle j'aimerais être petite
souris pour voir les discussions parce
qu'entre des représentants d'un indigène
is made solu de sociaux-démocrates et
des gens qui interdisent les bateaux à
voile et les sapins de noël
moi je souhaiterais dans la salle parce
que faudra qu'on m'explique mondes ps
peut s'entendre avec les banquiers
notent un avec les filles et comment
monsieur mélenchon peut être présenté
aujourd'hui comme un devant démocrates
nous parlant d'écologie moi je me
franchement si vous avez un
enregistrement je suis preneur parce que
ça va être extraordinaire
peut-être que vous tenez les mois à
venir et d'autres moins votre bouche
avant traité légende indigéniste déjà
présentes on est d'accord le débat
politique sur des bases un peu énorme
pour moi elle s'est perdue
merci madame pulvar a baissé les
soutiens qui ont été sévèrement les
manifestations je les assume totalement
propres délais à reprenez des enjeux
touchant les est vrai qu'elle avait
approuvé le le politique de l'ue 9 qui
était de faire comme moi j'étais
dirigeant de l'unef moment l'unef n'est
pas indigéniste d'ailleurs je sais pas
ce que j'ai dit et je pense qu'il faut
faire attention qu'on emploie sur des
plateaux télé il ya des face il ya des
pacifistes aurais je suis mes
responsabilités je vous dis que vous
avez trois candidats font également des
besoins différents albums totalement
différent comprenait des propos qui ne
peuvent pas être conciliées sauf sauf
dans notre tambouille politique qui
avait les gens ne pas voter
il ya des caricatures sur cette lycéenne
ces caricatures c'est pas donné de dire
la vérité est par contre masqué derrière
un brouillard effectivement pour ne pas
faire comprendre que sont trois
personnes qui ont des pouvoirs est
fondamentalement différent pour moi ces
montures aux allées bon train on est
extrêmement convergent sur la question
des transports par exemple on est les
seuls à avoir parlé d'un fonds
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures paix publique
on est les seuls à avoir parlé de baisse
des tarifs sur personne d'autre à part
les investissements dans les
infrastructures sont constamment on
aurait bien voulu entendre justement les
différences en bref quelque chose c'est
la vérité
la laïcité la laïcité dans le banat
licite et s'il me sauvegarde et non non
vous allez vous l'avez parlait que de ça
que dès qu'il y avait une possibilité de
dévier le débat social a aussi participé
plus de laïcité
segal mais contrairement à vous monsieur
c'est pas de la posture moi je ne
descends pas la vie oui monsieur vous
devriez vous renseigner sur qui je suis
mal peut-être que c'est un autre sujet
sur les transports c'est simple nous
ôter ses partie de ceux qui qui
proposait les investissements plus
d'investissements et les transports mais
surtout nous permettait de le financer
on n'allait pas avant des transports
gratuits ras puis en disant qu'on allait
en plus un vestiaire se peut que ça me
parle un peu compliqué donc je pense
qu'il faut le s'il faut s'éloigner de
trop caricaturer les candidats il faut
il faut aussi s'interroger sur le
pourquoi un peu sur la capacité à
rassembler des gens qui relie bus sont
partis différemment et sa rive ne pas
être très clair pour les élire patricia
bio vous êtes optimiste sur ces
rassemblements
mon âme au parce qu'il faut qu'on passe
au départemental oui moi je suis assez
optimiste je suis un peu écoeuré de la
caricature que j'entends la sur les
écologistes et le sapin de noël
franchement faudrait peut-être essayer
de comprendre les idées amende d déformé
à ce point parce que je trouve ça va mal
c'est assez insupportable at ans et je
pense que les idées de clémentine autain
comme d'audrey pulvar comme celle de
julien bayou peuvent faire un programme
bien sûr qu'il ya des choses sur
lesquelles on n'est pas d'accord sinon
seraient tous dans le même parti et ça
s'appellerait pas du pluralisme mais on
est capable de faire comme comme ça peut
se faire par exemple au parlement
européen où des choses se font et pas
forcément avec des gens qui sont qui
sont soudés même parti je pense qu'on
peut faire des compromis qui ne sont pas
des compromissions métissant des faucons
compromis sur des sujets et je pense
qu'avec avec les trois formations on est
tout à fait capable de produire un
programme qui sera applicable et
appliquée contrairement au programme de
valérie pécresse n'a pas été appliquée
dans ce qui était dans le social et dans
l'environnement talent et dans le lycée
dans les listes oui oui mais je pouvais
pas tout
explique non mais justement si on va
s'aimer mais très très rapidement 36%
c'est un très bon score et en même temps
quand dans le nord bertrand fait 43 que
wauquiez fait 44 en rhône alpes
est-ce que cela plombe pas pour les pour
un avenir éventuel présidentielle ce que
celle là mais pas la moins bien élu de
la droite mais pas aussi bon que ce
qu'elle aurait aimé vendre pendant cette
campagne
le rendement samet recyclage en
ile-de-france notion de morceler avec
des populations qui sont totalement
différents oui jakiel moins de 15 ans
baptiste oui la misère relative
relativisons aussi les scores c'est pas
pour faire c'est pas mon rôle était
celle de frais vie davantage par
l'avocate valérie pécresse là dessus et
surtout pas à l approche de la
présidentielle en tout cas si vous
prenez les scores de xavier bertrand et
laurent wauquiez
quand vous regardez leur score par
rapport à l'abstention finalement ils
font 13% des voir son voile à 10% des
voix on va parler des entreprises ont
aussi pardon au départ tant attendu
devrait il en était avant qu'on en parle
un mot encore sur les régionales
alors j'ai entendu une caricature du
représentant de 2 à l'air je crois
concernant une partie de la gauche la
gauche qui pourrait pas à s'unir parce
qu'elle aurait et l'arrêt des positions
totalement différentes qui vont répète
tout à l'heure que ceux qui ont suivi
les débats ont dû voir à quel point les
positions étaient proches c'était
extrêmement frappant donc j'imagine que
les négociations qui sont en cours vont
se faire sans trop de difficultés au
niveau au moins au niveau des fonds du
programme mais je voudrais
hélas moi aussi je mens sur la
caricature mais en le précisant répondre
aux représentants de à l'air donc que il
a aussi de l erreur enfin dans tous les
cas il a aussi ils ont aussi entrepris
aussi bien pu être valérie pécresse que
ça martin ddd propositions concernant la
sécurité de rappel je vais créer le ca
martin je vais créer une 500 500
policiers donc est ce que pour autant il
faut qu'on fasse ce genre de remarque si
vous avez des propositions qui sont très
proches de celles du r n est donc nous
et pas les meilleurs remparts contre le
rm jeu on se permet pas ce genre de
choses éviter les caricatures que vous
avez fait tout à l'heure ok c'est le
nôtre vous voulez commenter cette
affaire est la vois passer au
départemental
[Musique]
alors élections départementales bon bah
on va parler de votre compte en banque
la jolie c'était un des cantons que
compte qu'ils étaient surveillés
forcément scruté dans les yvelines
pierre bédier 36%
vous même vous avez 21 un peu moins de
22 %
c'est 37 37 19% y remédier vous un peu
moins de 22 % c'est un échec on subit on
subit l'abstention ce que vous avez fait
vous avez vous avez vous beaucoup
d'ardeur dans cette campagne tibet dit
oui
nous ne sommes pas les seuls nous ne
sommes pas les seuls nous avons tous
dénoncé pierre bédier son système
clientéliste islamo clientéliste y
compris la candidate falot binôme nerfs
em les camps les binômes de gauche ont
aussi dénoncé la corruption le mot a été
utilisé dans les tracts politiques
bah écoutez moi je t'invite j'invite
tous ces binômes à tirer les
conséquences de leurs de leurs graves
accusations et de tout faire pour au
second tour pour éliminer pierre bédier
y avait un candidat lrm en effet dans ce
dans ce canton
c'est pas le cas partout parce qu'il y
avait aussi des robes qui était sur la
liste de pierre bel ippon pourquoi il ya
eu des choix différents
il ya eu 5 5 me nomme de quoi il a même
qui ont été soutenue officiellement par
le mouvement il ya eu
deux autres décisions individuelles des
choix personnels de quela qui sont
portés sur la liste de paie y fait qu'on
a fait le choix de présenter peut-être
moins de candidats mais vraiment des
candidats qui étaient les candidats
citoyens issus de la société civile la
plupart nos élus ou très récemment élue
reine s'engager en politique
et on est allé vraiment sur les cantons
il y avait des des enjeux forts suez
demande suite trab qui était on avait
vraiment nous aussi un progrès à
défendre dans le département pour en
fait remettre département des yvelines
qui soit qu'ils soient simplement pas le
département des départements les plus
riches tout en étant l'avant dernier
dans les dépenses en terme de solidarité
et dans toutes ses compétences qui sont
les plus importantes et c'est ce projet
là qu'on a voulu défendre avec cinq
binômes répartis sur le département
reste que le président vous êtes en tête
à dans la ville dont il était maire dans
trois communes seules 5 e magnanville
buchelay et mantes la ville
je bats pierre bédier de 75 voix malgré
malgré le fait que son binôme soit la
première adjointe de nantes la ville
donc ça me fait effectivement
extrêmement plaisir j'en profite pour
remercier chaleureusement les et
mandeville way cela démontre que tous
les manduellois ne sont pas ne sont pas
à vendre
c'est à dire que depuis un an avant à
vendre oui à vendre c'est à dire au
moins par des subventions qui sont une
méthode légale d'achat puisque quand on
déverse près de 11 millions d'euros de
promesses de subventions puisque à ce
stade ce ne sont que des promesses mais
11 millions d'euros de subventions en un
an à opoul indo poulains de pierre
bédier à savoir le nouveau maire de la
comédie n'est pas là donc oui mais en
l'occurrence et c'est la réalité je suis
je suis malgré tout en tête et je m'en
félicite sur batista monique vous vous
êtes le modem a fait alliance avec avec
p y
en somme pour les yvelines où vous êtes
satisfait de cette alliance oui mais
vous c'est une alliance c'est ce que je
disais depuis qui date depuis l'année
2015 depuis le précédent scrutin
départemental
on n'avait pas eu la chance de pouvoir
avoir à cette époque des candidats et
donc des élus en revanche là c'est vrai
que on s'est entendus très tôt sur le
projet et sur l'ambition qu'on
souhaitait porter sur le département ce
premier tour des départementales il est
quand même très positif puisque
finalement il n'ya uniquement je crois
de caen sur lesquels les binômes et y
eux n'arrivent pas en tête avec quatre
ou cinq cantons voire plus où on dépasse
les 50 % pour le blé mais peu y alors
évidemment toujours en raison de ce
faible taux de participation il faudra
repasser devant les électeurs dimanche
prochain mais je pense aux cantons
poissy où karl olive et son binôme fait
60% à saint-germain-en-laye avec arnaud
péri arnaud péricard kéfa 61 je pense au
comptant de chatou à 60% bonbons qui on
voit que là aussi l'implantation locale
le bilan sont des choses auxquelles des
électeurs sont très sensibles maintenant
il va falloir confirmer tout ça mon
week-end prochain et si vous me
permettez mais je suis sûr que de rome à
sourire dira mot un motif de
satisfaction c'est une résultats sur le
canton de trappes où on nous avait
annoncé en tout cas oui on nous avait
annoncé que ce serait très compliqué et
que la gauche avait gagné ce concours
sans difficulté je crois que quand on
regarde aujourd'hui les résultats on
voit quand même que ça va être compliqué
c'est pas gagné mais qu' il ya match il
ya match et moi je remercie vraiment en
tout cas je soutiens m capio et dénis
coderre david qui ont réalisé un
excellent mandat au conseil
départemental qui sont deux élus très
engagé et qui auront à coeur de
démontrer qu'ils sont les meilleurs
candidats possibles pour le canton
dimanche prochain les roms ça va être
important dans ce contrat porte à près
de 10% mais vous pouvez pas rester
évidemment on lisse il va y avoir un
désistement va y avoir un désistement on
n'est pas qualifiés donc le délai rapide
à un appel
on est encore en train de discuter
aujourd'hui on va on va se voir on va
voir un comité politique ce soir qui
perd en prendre à ce genre de décision
d'accord vous viendrez à l'irs avait oui
alors que se tenait au premier tour il
avait l'étiquette france insoumise on
continuera à le soutenir au second je
pense que le fruit de son court bilan
commence déjà enfin voilà son court
bilan pardon commence déjà à proposer
d'autant que en tant que maire de
trappes donc on soutiendra à fond cette
liste est juste pour revenir sur ce qui
se passait dans le mantois
on voit aussi que le plus une élection à
un faible taux de participation le plus
le résultat final va se jouer en fait
sur les réseaux militants et sur la
capacité de réseauter dans dans un
certain nombre de cercles c'est quand
même la spécialité de monsieur bédié on
va pas se mentir on le sait tous ici
et donc nous on a quand même mené une
liste qui arrive en troisième position
avec 17% audrey alliés candidats de
france insoumise avec une liste d'union
de la gauche
maintenant si on veut mettre fin au
système bédié on n'a pas le choix il
faudra une mobilisation populaire et
pour une mobilisation populaire fait des
élections avec un taux de participation
un peu plus élevé sinon la salle à
béziers continuera oui on peut faire
beaucoup de reproches à pierre bédier
c'est pas sa faute s'il ya des gens sont
pas les jeter pierre bédier n'est pas
encore élu contrairement à ce
qu'annonçait l'infographie tout à
l'heure mais alors bien second tour
vient secondes et 2 enfin tu es plus de
deux 2 candidats deux nomme laurent
mazaury sur lui je reversais du canton
oui alors burnand je laisse le montois
s'exprimer je suis je partage une partie
de ce qui a été dit sur la complexité
fait qu'effectivement il faut faire
revenir des électeurs aux urnes demain
de toute façon pour départager
l'ensemble des candidats sur celui de
trappes s'est parlé de réseautage on a
un petit peu aussi dans ceux dans ce cas
de figure là puisque on sait tous les
particularités de trappes et la verrière
les complexités locales que l'on rend
compte c'est effectivement un très très
bon résultat pour ensemble pour les
yvelines et pour anne capio ma collègue
et lui d'ailleurs elle en cours et
nicolas neuville e mail
le maire de la verrière c'est pas gagné
c'est pas gagné le combat dans continuer
je pense que les différents partis et
mouvements qui vont se retirer seront
appelés s'ils tentaient qu'on n'est
propriétaire de ses électeurs
les électeurs à rejoindre effectivement
la candidature d'ensemble pour les
yvelines après on voit que c'est très
serré et c'est historiquement toujours
le cas sur un accident dans lequel qui
plus est l'abstention est souvent plus
forte qu'ailleurs
je trouve d'ailleurs que globalement la
mobilisation s'est plutôt bien faite des
deux côtés et ça on peut satisfaire
vraiment féliciter les électeurs des
deux de tous les camps d'être venus
voter
j'espère qu'ils voteront encore plus
fort la la semaine prochaine et puis
évidemment que les deux candidats dans
son poésie vinh sur l'en-tête patricia
bio et j'accédais vous allez mettre
l'accent il nous reste quelques secondes
à peine
sur ce canton dans son canton
nous nous soutenir ali rabais son équipe
aille a pas de il n'y a pas de raison
qu'on change entre les deux tours même
si aux municipales que nous l'avons fait
pour d'autres réseaux là je ferai quand
même remarquer à la droite que les
sortants n'ont pas de primes
manifestement là on n'entend plus parler
t et puis deuxièmement les primes il me
semble mais peut-être que je fais une
erreur que la dernière fois
la droite était en tête et locaux
étaient en tête sur ce canton au premier
tour donc la situation totalement
différente et j'espère que là la prime
ira celui qui est en tête ce qui est un
mot pour conclure
est ce que vous espérez ou est ce qu'on
peut espérer une mobilisation plus forte
des électeurs pour le deuxième tour oui
ou non très rapidement virus
allez-y patricia bardon et de ce que
pensent les écologistes en 10 sélections
départementales
allez-y resic vous écoute
donc je voulais donner la satisfaction
des écologistes sur l'oder parce que je
pense que par exemple dans le canton de
rambouillet jeu grand plaisir d'être au
deuxième tour et d'être devant le front
national ce qui est la première fois
depuis bien longtemps
et quant aux élections à date à 3 monte
je pense que
le clientélisme de pierre bédier est en
opposition au front national c'est aux
électeurs de décider ce qu'ils préfèrent
je ne suis pas sûr que nous donnerons
une consigne de vote mais c'est aux
ehome aux candidats locaux de se
déterminer quant à trappes
je pense que cette alliance qui était
large de la gauche et des écologistes je
rappelle que les écologistes sont dans
cette alliance à mon avis augure plutôt
bien et il faut absolument qu'on fasse à
beaucoup appel aux abstentionnistes
parce que c'est eux qui vont faire la
différence
vous avez bien dit qu entre autres
pierre bédier leur assemblée nationale
vous ne choisissez pas à titre personnel
j'aurais beaucoup de mal à choisir je ne
sais pas ce que je ferai et je pense que
c'est aux candidats locaux ou de prendre
leur décision
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour oui c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle non mais faut
il faut il faut savoir ce que l'on veut
dans la vie si on veut éliminer pierre
bédier il faut voter syrie est nôtre
c'est le seul moyen de l'éliminer voilà
c'est clair frey comme vous avez toute
une semaine pour faire campagne
merci merci à tous malheureusement
l'émission est terminée merci à tous
pardon pour les enduits un peu de
technique du début on aura peut-être
l'occasion de se retrouver au j'espère
le lendemain du deuxième tour c'est à
dire lundi prochain merci à tous
[Musique]